[Music]
what is this obviously an arrow right
well probably not for those with the
knowledge of vectors yes by now we're
very well acquainted with the idea of
representing a vector by an arrow its
length represents the magnitude of the
vector and the arrowhead the direction
of the vector now moving on we're going
to look at an interesting concept called
components of a vector to begin with
instead of diving right into the concept
let's first intuitively understand what
is it all about we know that any natural
number can be written as a repeated
addition of the number 1 2 can be
written as 1 plus 1 which is 2 times 1 3
1 plus 1 plus 1 that is 3 times 1 and so
on so any natural number is just the
number 1 added to itself a few times
similarly for vectors there exists some
special vectors similar to the number 1
these vectors I hat J hat and k hat are
some examples of them in the
three-dimensional space they act like
the number 1 for different directions
like this so for example suppose we have
a vector a in the 3d space then it can
be decomposed into addition of these
vectors like this don't worry about what
all these symbols mean we will
understand them in detail but for now
the point is that similar to the natural
numbers a vector can be decomposed into
a set of special elementary vectors for
example consider another vector B in
three-dimensional space decomposed as
this basically we can say that these two
examples tell us that any vector in a 3d
space is just made up of these three
vectors here
these individual vectors are called the
components of the vector the
is that as we learn more about vectors
we will see how important and useful
this idea is it makes dealing with
vectors a lot easier for example suppose
we want to add these vectors then we
will see that to get the resultant
vector we just have to add the
components of the vectors like this
interesting right these components makes
the addition of vectors as simple as
adding numbers this was just a glimpse
of the whole idea to show you the bigger
picture let's move ahead and understand
what exactly the components of a vector
mean for this we'll start by
understanding what these special vectors
are these are called
unit vectors consider a vector C
represented by this arrow now let me ask
you a question what if we multiply this
vector by this number 1 over magnitude
of vector C can you tell me what would
be the magnitude and direction of this
vector okay let's see remember we have
seen that multiplying a scalar lambda
that is a number lambda by a vector a
gives us a new vector the magnitude of
this new vector is equal to the absolute
value of lambda times the magnitude of
vector a and its direction is the same
as that of vector a if lambda is a
positive number or opposite to that of
vector a if lambda is a negative number
so let's look at our question again here
we multiply by the number 1 over
magnitude of vector C so the magnitude
of the new vector will be this which
turns out to be 1 and since the number
is a positive number the direction of
the new vector will be that of the
vector C so we get a vector with
magnitude 1 in the direction of the
vector C this vector is called the unit
vector in the direction of vector C it's
denoted by a symbol like a hat above the
letter pronounced as
hat let's represent it like this with
arrow so a unit vector is simply a
vector whose magnitude is equal to one
this speciality of the unit vector is
that it just specifies a particular
direction therefore the advantage of a
unit vector is that we can use it to
express any vector which is along its
direction let's take a few examples and
understand this suppose we have these
two vectors D and E directed in the same
direction as that of vector C now
consider the vector magnitude of vector
D times the vector C hat as the
magnitude of vector C hat is 1 the
magnitude of this vector will be equal
to that of vector D and since the vector
C hat and D are directed in the same
direction the vector D will be equal to
this vector similarly vector e will be
equal to the magnitude of vector e times
the vector C hat and here is well we
could write the vector C to be equal to
the magnitude of vector C times the
vector C hat so now the idea of a unit
vector is very clear to us but we still
have to understand what component
vectors actually mean let's see that in
the next lesson to stay updated and to
keep learning such interesting concepts
to subscribe to our channel
you
[Music]